- [Narrator] Like a scene out of Frozen,
in the mountains of Shanxi
Province, in Northern China
lie the Luyashan Mountain's
Ningwu ice caves,
a spectacle of icicles, ice
falls and ice stalagmites.
(energetic music)
These caves are thought to have formed
around three million years
ago, during an early ice age.
And while there are many caves
like this around the world,
the Ningwu caves are special
for one particular reason.
This cave stays frozen all year long.
While temperatures can reach
up to 70 degrees outside
in the summer, the temperature inside
never rises above 32 degrees.
Scientists believe this is due
to the cave's natural bowling pin shape,
which traps cold air inside.
Stretching thousands of feet down,
the top 300 feet are open to the public,
with five layers connected by
a winding maze of ice stairs,
holes and bridges.
Established as a national park in 2005,
the caves are staged with colorful lights
emphasizing the grandness
of this ancient cavern.
It is truly a sight to behold.